You might be surprised to find the idea...
...behind the shorter length kilt as we know it today...
...did not originate in Scotland.
The idea actually came from an English Quaker called Thomas Rawlinson from Lancashire...
...back in the 1720s.
Rawlinson thought the great kilt was too much...
...and he decided to split the garment...
...and create one distinct piece running from the waist to the middle knee.
Lo and behold, the small kilt,...
...or in Gaelic, "feileadh beag," pronounced "feela beg", was born.
Rawlinson started wearing the small kilt and so did some of his peers.
Before long, it was adopted by the Highlanders and even some Lowlanders.
The Scottish kilt is bold, unique and unmatched by other garments.
The garment usually wraps around the lower body, usually from the left hip,...
...going around the front, and back around the front again to the opposite side,...
...where it is then fastened.
The kilt goes down from the hip to the middle of the knee.
Moving swiftly on, the modern-day kilt is made of twill woven, worsted wool.
The way it's woven creates a distinctive pattern known as tartan.
Historically, specific patterns were associated with different clans and families.
It wasn't until the Victorian era...
...that specific patterns were systemically recorded and formalized.